credit where credit is due props to Sony
for making a dark universe trilogy
before Universal could even make a dark
universe at all
[Music]
Hotel Transylvania 3 so Hotel
Transylvania 3 is the third movie in the
Hotel Transylvania movies full
disclosure I never saw the second one I
don't even know why I don't remember why
sure it was a weekend who's just like it
I got other things to do but this stars
the voice talent of Adam Sandler and his
crew we can say his crew right we all
know who his crew is Adam Sandler plays
Dracula and the rest of his friends play
monsters you also live Selena Gomez who
plays his daughter and they go out there
on vacation on a cruise and Dracula kind
of gets lovestruck I wonder what's gonna
happen trust me by the time you see her
you know exactly how it's gonna go down
so much so I feel like I can spoil the
movie for you because nothing's gonna
surprise you you're not going to that
I'm not gonna spoil it what I liked
about the movies I like the animation
style that the animation style is fun
someone gets hit it does that one friend
from here to here it's Samurai Jack
animation sometimes people do that thing
where their heads moving differently
than their body like their head staying
still and their body is just like a limp
noodle going everywhere it translated
well to a kids movie and it translated
well to a kids movie with monsters
that's really where my enjoyment of the
movie dies this movie was a bit too much
for me and by too much I mean it was too
much where it needed less and it wasn't
enough where it needed more the plot is
pretty basic so basic in fact I feel
like the main plot of this movie is 5
pages of script but it's the kids movie
we gotta entertain kids right so let's
entertain kids with sensory overload the
likes of which to keep up you will need
coke I mean the soda with caffeine kids
but you totally do this movie attempted
to be fun and it was for a bit but to
the point of being exhausted ever go to
someone's house and they have kids and
they have something playing on the
screen for kids and it's just things are
happening apparently we need to bombard
kids with sensory overload it was like
that but an animated monster movie form
in any one scene will have a few
monsters in the foreground in the
background and just things are happening
and they're just doing stuff you're like
not everyone needs to be doing something
calm down stop take a breath at the guy
who uses jump cuts in his reviews but
it's true and to fill time the movies
just comprised of blocks of jokes just
joke next scene joke next scene joke
next scene jokes just really short jokes
in succession like links on a chain I
didn't feel like it was fluid with the
plot I just felt like these jokes
existed they stood out like a sore thumb
the plots going on over here and you
just have to cut these monsters 4 4
jokes sake because I have nothing else
to do and the jokes are always comprised
of the fact that they're monsters they
do things differently than us but they
try to do the same things as I've got to
get scuba gear on but they're monsters
so it's gonna react differently to that
you got to go swimming but they're
monsters so they're gonna look different
doing it the jokes in this movie just
get old pretty fast I just felt
repetitive I didn't find most of the
jokes in this movie funny the joke in
this movie they got the biggest laugh
was a fart joke take that as you well is
that stacked into a frame where there's
too much going on at any given moment
it's so dense every frame has so much
going on we've heard it before wasn't
good then not great now he has such
sensory overload in fact all this
missing is that soundbite you know the
one thing I like the most actually above
the animation was actually the message
where it has the basic message of
monsters may look different than us but
it doesn't mean they're not the same but
this movie makes an attempt to go a
little deeper I'm not saying they go
full ending of American History X or
anything like that but this will be
delve into an angle of how it exists I
thought that was really gutsy and really
impressive where most movies just stop
at the fact of the matter and stop at
the what they stop at the fact of
addressing that prejudices exist the
fact that it addressed the house well
anyway anyway I'm not saying there's
like the way this one thing that happens
that causes prejudice but I liked how it
showed how they have a tendency to get
passed down now if only that message was
in a movie that was better
that'd be ideal in the end I'm watching
this movie and I just felt like it was a
straight-to-dvd movie but it's not about
me it's about the consumers the kids did
laugh in a few parts sometimes they were
talking I don't know if they were
talking about the movie or asking their
parents about the movie I couldn't hear
exactly what they were saying I just
knew they were talking the mom seemed to
be having a good time with it the dads
were rubbing their eyes just getting
situated so I feel like if you're a mom
you'll do fine with it if you're a dad
you'll wish you were somewhere else and
if you're a kid you get a free movie so
live it up honestly speaking I'm
probably not gonna remember this movie
in t-minus one day he already forgot
that's right a lot of people in the
comment section say they can tell where
my videos gonna go by looking at the
thumbnail that's a thumbnail what do you
think of that
you know subscribing are you okay
alright so Hotel Transylvania 3 have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]